if you're not playing Metro Exodus on
the hardest difficulty you're doing it
all wrong
just only mithril nothing else for the
uninitiated the metro games are bleak
atmospheric first-person shooters that
take place in post-apocalyptic moscow
resources and ammo are scarce deadly
pockets of radiation are everywhere and
there aren't many people you can trust
in order to survive you'll need to
manage your air filters ammo crafting
components and equipment if fallout is a
waxy post-apocalyptic romp in Metro is a
kick your teeth in oppressive
post-apocalyptic Odyssey what is metros
hardest difficult do you ask
it's called Ranger hardcore it gets rid
of most if not all of the HUD there are
fewer work benches fewer resources the
AI is smarter you die quicker and your
gun jams more often from there you can
choose between a limited HUD or a full
dive which means no HUD at all right now
you might be thinking dang Jake maybe I
should play this on easier normal wrong
to get the most out of this game it
needs to hurt you should feel scared
vulnerable underpowered and
underprepared for basically the entire
game sure you may be fighting giant mole
rats big-ass worms and mutant bears but
what makes this series so special is how
grounded and realistic it looks and
feels luckily for you me being the
professional games journalist and
post-apocalyptic prepper i am i have
decided to play Metro Exodus on Ranger
hard core with absolutely no HUD so
you'll know what to expect when you play
the game for yourself right here I'd
like to reiterate that there's
absolutely no HUD if you pick full dive
no button prompts no QuickTime prompts
nothing this shouldn't come as a
surprise since I being the hardcore
gamer I am decided to play Metro Exodus
on Ranger hard core with the full dive
setting turn on most of the relevant
information you can find on our teams
risk your watch lets you know and you
should swap filters your Geiger counter
shows your radiation levels this blue
light shows your visibility and your
compass shows where your next objective
is information that isn't accounted for
is how many filters you have left how
much ammo you have and what throwable
items you have equipped if you're in a
safe spot you can check your resources
by opening the crafting menu but keep in
mind that time does
and stop when you do this you also won't
have crosshairs or hit markers so if you
want to aim while hip firing you'll need
to equip a laser sight even if you
decide to plan an easier difficulty I
recommend turning these off to begin
with because they look hideous
the one thing that ended up being a pain
without the HUD was managing throwable
objects normally you hold C on PC and a
menu pops up in the corner where you can
select what kind of throwable you want
to quit unruhe hardcore full dive you're
kind of left in the dark you will hear
sound effects when you equip different
throwables though so that should help
but if you want to play on Ranger
hardcore on your first run I'd recommend
memorizing this menu now I leave it in
the corner for the duration of this
video just for you know HUD also means
no button prompts which means if you
haven't played Metro since 2013 then
chances are you probably don't remember
what you can and can't interact with if
you see a small crawlspace press the
interact button and our team will enter
it lockers boxes baskets and ammo crates
can usually emphasis unusually be opened
and don't forget to loot down enemies
and strip their guns of ammo and spare
parts once I figured out all that things
were going smoothly I rescued this guy
stuff my way through a train station met
up with Anna and conveniently shot up
this computer for plot reasons once we
escaped Moscow I found myself glued to
this chair while my fictional wife and
my terrifying father-in-law argued
Miller told me to find a signal on a
radio great there's a radio right next
to me this should be easy I thought my
wife and father-in-law continued to
argue occasionally glancing over at me
asking if I had found a signal yet
clearly my wife in her terrifying
Russian father wanted me to use this
device conveniently placed next to me
but I simply couldn't one would think
that if I looked at the object in
question and press the interact button
Artyom being the resourceful fellow he
is would interact with said object I
pressed every button on that keyboard
multiple times I plugged in a controller
and hit every single button but it was
to no avail could our team be paralyzed
by fear I thought I remain in the chair
for a few minutes to see how things
would play out but nothing happened
eventually I did the only thing I could
think of restart the game with minimal
HUD so I could figure out what the [ __ ]
was going on now is probably a good time
to mention that if you choose to play
Ranger hardcore you can't change the
difficulty
ever after I rescued the engineer again
crept through the train station again
met up with Anna again and boarded the
train again I was back in the cursed
chair all the key players were there the
radio the cursed chair my wife and her
angry Russian father but this time
things were different this time there
was a prompt and it was to hold D on the
keyboard until this animation was
complete and then I could fiddle with
the radio pretty [ __ ] kidding me
the radio was to my left shouldn't I
have held a knot d once I made it past
that roadblock I reloaded my Ranger
hardcore fold I've saved which was a bit
of a pain because you can only have one
save file so I had to copy this save to
my desktop before starting a new game
and then overwrite my other save now
that I dip my feet into metros icy
irradiated waters I decided it was time
to show the good people of YouTube just
how hardcore I am willing to be for this
franchise first I decided to apply some
restrictions on myself
the first was I can't reload unless my
magazine is dry why would I do that you
ask well in reality if you fired a few
shots from magazine through that
magazine on the ground and reloaded
you'd be wasting a [ __ ] ton of ammo
maybe that's okay for consumerist
capitalist swine but not for me and
Artyom my second rule was that our team
needed asleep there are safe houses
scattered around the locations you visit
and you can use these spots to craft
items and sleep typically you'd want to
sleep until night in order to sneak into
a bandit camp or sleep until morning
when the monsters go to bed but since
I'm playing on Ranger hardcore that
wasn't enough for me if our team stayed
up for nights even weeks on end there's
no way he'd be able to safely operate
all this dangerous machinery and my
third and final rule was that no matter
who I killed how many resources I waste
or how much I botched the scenario I
wouldn't reload my safe I wanted our
team to live with his decisions and
fuck-ups oh and I changed the language
to Russian and remove the subtitles
because there's no way these hardened
Russian soldiers would be speaking the
tongue of capitalist pigs
the studio user whose motto is antivenom
Noga from this arose a new issue one I
typically haven't experienced in a
videogame
I had absolutely no [ __ ] idea what
anyone was saying what I was supposed to
do and where I was supposed to go
I felt like Tom Hanks in the terminal
except I was stuck in a post-apocalyptic
Russia and everyone was demanding things
of me and Russian stoled dude on the
right menu your starter this I thought
to myself as I leaned back in my chair
and put my hands behind my head this is
how Metro Exodus was meant to be played
you've really done it this time Jake
Trotsky Lenin Kamenev and if say ovitch
xenovia would be proud
[Music]
I also changed all the in-game text to
Russian my first challenge was to use my
memory to figure out where continue was
in the main menu well this may seem like
a formidable hurdle for a less
experienced gamer than myself it didn't
hinder my progress all that much there
were two important tools that guided me
through this trying time and no beer
wasn't one of them but hey hey it
certainly helped make sure to equip this
thing at a workbench when you have a
chance the second was an iPhone with
Google Translate and let me tell you
Google Translate on text worked wonders
all I had to do was hold my phone up to
the screen and it would translate in
real time as you can see it worked
flawlessly a co-worker later informed me
that if I was trying to play this as
realistically as possible artyom
probably doesn't have a smartphone with
cell service on him at all times I
calmly asked my comrade to leave this
set I think the final piece of this
sprawling Ranger hardcore puzzle is
patience I'm gonna level with you I died
a lot and if I died a lot that means
you're gonna die it's significantly more
fortunately Metro Exodus has an almost
too generous autosave system that you
can't turn off in the menus I rarely
lost more than a minute or two of
progress
now I understand not everyone is as
hardcore gamer is me and playing Metro
like this may seem a little daunting
most casuals like to be able to
understand what characters are saying in
their favorite video games so I guess
you can probably set the voice-acting to
your desired language and if you think
Ranger hardcore might be too much for
you start with hardcore that way you can
scale back the difficulty if things get
too hard I guess the point I'm trying to
make with this long-winded video is that
whether you're a longtime fan of the
series or this is your first don't be
afraid to push yourself the game and
series for that matter is at its very
best when you and Artyom are at your
very worst even if you decide to plan an
easier difficulty turn off the hood take
your time
live with the choices you make along the
way
[Music]
Oh
Oh
[Music]